the new California Senator lansa Butler
she was the one immediately named by
governor Patrick baitman uh to fill the
seat vacated when Dian Feinstein died
she is the president of em EMILY's List
EMILY's List is a group that works to
elect pro-abortion women to public
office so she's a real she's a treat but
there's a problem which is that she is
the senator from California but she
doesn't live in California she lives in
Maryland and if you go to the website of
Emily's List her her Maryland residence
was listed there until they scrubbed it
in mid-september Rob Pyers who's a
research director of the California
Target book looks at all these Finance
filings uh this woman was listed as
being a Maryland resident as recently as
August 31st so is that going to take her
out is Le fansa Butler no longer going
to be the senator the senat Trix from
California uh no no one's going to Care
nobody's going to care at all